TV you break our hearts we give you
hours of our time and you promise us a
level of consistent bliss and then you
stab us right in the back during the
course of almost any great TV show
you'll find at least one disastrously
off-key episode expect spoilers here are
a few TV shows nearly ruined by one
episode the worst episode ever The
Walking Dead thank you the world's most
popular zombie show has enough suspense
and desperate relationship dynamics to
keep itself going indefinitely which is
just one reason why the season 6 episode
thank you didn't need to happen like it
did Glenn's fake out dumpster death was
the first time the showrunners pulled a
deceptive camera trick even though the
viewers quickly saw through the ruse
they were not quick to forgive The
Walking Dead changed from a
straightforward post-apocalyptic drama
into a show that was comfortable
deceiving the audience much to the
disappointment of the audience similar
camera tricks made a controversial
reappearance during this season six
finale The Simpsons natural-born kisses
critics often debate the exact point
when the once amazing Simpsons began to
crumble though slate the New York Post
and plenty of other cultural pundits all
seem to agree that it was somewhere
during the ninth and tenth seasons so
it's fair to choose the ninth season
finale as the definitive point where the
show was no longer the series when you
and loved since even the official
Simpsons website admits that the
popularity of that season was subpar the
off key overtly sexual theme of
natural-born kisses could be attributed
to the fact that it was right at Matt
Selman first crack at the show but
quality control had already shown signs
of slipping viewers started tuning out
by the time season 10 premiere one point
six million viewers had already left
making it the lowest viewed Simpsons
premiere until season 25
oh man yet good Xena Warrior Princess
lifeblood there are hundreds of Xena
moments that test the downward limits of
good TV but viewers will never forget
the laziness of season fives lifeblood
in an attempt to build an unstoppable
trifecta of ancient adventurers geared
to modern audiences hercules and xena
producer Rob Tapert created Amazon high
a two-hour pilot about a modern girl
transported to the time of the original
Amazons the network wasn't into it
so tapper cut the footage down and
crammed it into an episode of zener
instead adding ghosts and baby
sacrifices despite featuring sci-fi
royalty like selma Blair Karl Urban and
Claudia black the sliced and diced
episode just confused viewers watching
the episode was a labor that even
Hercules couldn't have handled Doctor
Who nightmare and silver you can easily
find a few thousand blog entries with
titles like why I quit Doctor Who or the
doctor is out and they all have their
own ideas of where dr. who jumped the
shark may be the breaking point is the
episode nightmare and silver the doctor
brings some kids to a decommissioned
amusement park but instead of using his
time machine to bring them back to a
time when it wasn't a dangerous ruin
crawling with Cybermen they hang out
worst babysitter of all time the entire
episode is a series of unusually huge
plot holes which radio Times called
exact ripple a flop and underwhelming
which are polite British code words for
oh you're just destroyed everything good
in this world
Twin Peaks the man behind the glass
David Lynch is allowed a greater
weirdness quotient than almost any other
director
that is crazy but the man behind the
gloss during the second season of the
cult classic Twin Peaks marks the spot
where fans started to lose their
enchantment for no discernible reason
resident bad-boy James decides to bust
out a guitar and sing a sleepy Ultra
falsetto ballad to a couple of girls
[Music]
and the ladies join him in an impromptu
sing-along along with other invisible
instruments it's the least believable
part of a show that actively
incorporated well stuff like this thanks
for watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which TV episodes you
almost think ruined your favorite shows
[Music]